Hello Dr Peterson,
I've been trying to listen to my
conscience,
but I can't tell the difference between
fear,
willful blindness or genuine conscience.
Well,
the first thing I would say about that
is it is quite clear that you are in
fact trying to listen to your conscience
because that's probably the first thing
that you discover,
so that's a really good question.
Okay,
fear.
Well,
here's a test and you don't want to do
this stupidly.
If you think that you should do
something and you think that the reason
you might not be doing it is because
you're afraid,
then you should do it.
So that way you can find out if it's
fear.
No,
I think your question is,
well,
how do I know my conscience isn't just
masquerading as fear saying,
well,
you shouldn't do that,
but it's rationalizing the real issue,
which is you're afraid of doing that.
Now,
see,
here's a reason that you want to tell
the truth.
And I parked.
I kind of figured this out when I was
looking deeply into the Pinocchio Story.
You know when Pinocchio as Pinocchio
strives to become real,
he,
he has a conscience to guide him,
but it's jimminy cricket,
this insect,
but Gemini isn't really a very good
conscience.
He's a bit dogmatic to begin with,
dogmatic and didn't experienced,
and so it's.
It's not like the conscience is an
unerring guide.
It's like a partner in discovery and as
you move forward in your life and you
consult your conscience and you listened
to it,
then it gets smarter and so to you,
but there's a Coda there,
and this is why I've suggested part of
the reason why I've suggested so
frequently in my lectures and in my book
that people try not to lie.
See,
there are many systems.
You have many systems within.
Let's say that guide you and one of
those is your capacity for rational
thought and then you have a variety of
emotional systems and motivational
systems and internal dramas and
intuitions and bodily sensations like
lots and lots of incenses.
Lots of systems that are guiding you and
many of them operate.
You might say,
unconsciously,
autonomously,
instinctively,
implicitly,
all of that.
Now you pr nonetheless,
you programmed them like you feed them
content,
let's say just like you feed your body
nourishment,
you feed them content and a lot of the
content that you feed them pertains
directly to your voluntary thoughts and
speech and your actions and then if you
pathologize those by lying,
so if you say things that you know not
to be true or you don't say things that
you know to be true when you need to,
which is more common and if you act in
ways that you consider that an act in
ways you considered reprehensible,
then you pathologize all of those
autonomous systems that guide you.
It's like you're programming them badly.
You're building an AI system inside
yourself really in in,
in some sense that is what you're doing.
That has very bad.
It's very bad training data and so the
output it produces will be will,
won't guide you properly and so you
don't want to pathologize your guidance
systems.
It's a really bad idea.
So that's why you have to not lie and
maybe that's also why you have to say
what you have to say and you have to say
clearly as well and you have to learn
how to do that.
So that's one of the ways of getting
your conscience straightened out.
And then you have to have a dialogue
with your conscience and you might ask.
It's like,
okay,
well what should I do or what should,
should I do this or should I not do
this?
So let's say you're thinking,
should I not do this?
In the case of a temptation,
maybe you have a chance to develop a new
relationship.
You know,
and you're,
you're excited about it and apprehensive
about it and afraid of it and you don't
know how to sort out all those feelings.
And the first thing is you really have
to want to sort them out.
That's why you have to orient yourself
to something that's a genuine up.
You know that the star above the
horizon,
you have to really want things to be
straight and you have to have thought
that through.
And you have to know what it means for
things not to be straight,
and really what it means is that you're
headed for hell in one way or another.
And if you understand that it's enough,
maybe it's enough to scare you straight.
You really gotta think that through.
Then you've got to think about how much
better it would be if you aimed up and
and that really has to kind of permeate
your whole being.
And so then you're oriented that way
you're oriented to adopt and you're
deciding that it's okay to try to tell
the truth and then you can start to rely
on this dialogue with your conscience.
But both of you have to learn and you're
gonna make mistakes along the way.
You know that's okay.
You can say,
well,
I'm going to try this without being
certain that it's right.
You can even say,
I'm going to say this without being
certain that it's correct.
Like if you're arguing with your wife or
your husband or your or your sister,
your father,
and you have an idea about what might be
going on.
You can say,
look,
here's my idea about what's going on,
who knows what that idea might be
contaminated with like,
maybe I'm putting it forward just
because I'm too proud or arrogant or
angry or fearful or whatever that's
possible.
Let's see if we can figure that out.
But you can offer it tentatively and
both have at it.
That's what you do.
If it's a hypothesis,
right.
You both have at it and see if it's an
idea that's worthy of,
of keeping you do that with your
conscience.
And then you were moved forward.
There's a,
there's a technique in behavioral
psychology called psychotherapy called
collaborative empiricism.
So let's say that we,
you and I have been sitting down and we
decided that you're going to try
something new this week,
like maybe your agoraphobic and you're
having a hard time in a parking lot and
so getting out of the car and going to
the grocery store.
So maybe we say,
well,
you know,
drive to the grocery store and you're
just gonna walk halfway to the two,
halfway from your car to the door and
that's good enough for like,
do that every second day for a week and
then come back and let's talk about it.
So that's collaborative empiricism.
You're running little experiments,
you think what your conscience is
guiding you towards something.
You take a tentative step in that
direction and then you check and see,
well,
you know,
did what I wanted to have happen or
occur as an outcome.
That's the crucial question and that's
the crucial question for behavioral
truth,
right?
That's the pragmatic perspective.
Did what I want to have happened happen
as a consequence of my framework of
interpretation and my action.
If the answer is yes,
then I have not invalidated it.
Right?
That's,
that's the pragmatic philosophy in a
nutshell.
And it's,
it's very,
very smart.
So you have a dialogue with your
conscience that never ends and hopefully
it gets wiser and you get wiser.
And
that's the dialogue that young talked
about between the conscious and the
unconscious,
between your,
your fantasy life.
Say the life that sort of underneath you
as a conscious being like the life
that's part of your biological platform,
the biological platform that somehow
miraculously gives rise to your
consciousness.
If a dialogue with that.
We're always in dialogue.
We're always in dialogue,
right with everything,
so pursue that.